when I play basketball with you know
older older men that like they no longer
have their like burst of speed they no
longer have as much strength as they
used to it to have and I never really
believed them that you know they're like
well we had to change our game we had to
get smarter like we just have to play
different like Nam and that's never
going to happen to me like but as age
creeps up the reality is that stuff
catches up to you and your reflexes kind
of start to dull a little bit you got to
play smarter yeah yo look my Fiat boss
like George Steinberg sign Ernie when
I'm fine I'll just bring it up serve a
lot of nerve for nerds I got to put the
her spread my news with the word
Ferb legit goofy I don't feel like I
have the same reaction speeds as some of
these younger younger teenagers do maybe
that's an excuse I don't know but it's
definitely changed how I play a game
like a game like cod because I'll do
these so fast paced there's constant
action all the time I can't just keep
running around all the time and hope
that if I see someone else I'm gonna win
and look like find a good spot on the
map that you know that you can cover or
that you can get hit by or hit less by
your opponent's so that you're not
exposed just trying to run and gun the
whole time you know maybe in the past
you know like three years ago or
something like that I could do that and
be like really competitive there's this
online thing of just you know if you're
if an opponent kills you and you didn't
really like how they killed you because
like they camped you or whatever their
chances are they're going to come back
to that same spot to get you again
friendly you wait for you both now being
a wily old veteran I guess you know that
they're going to come back right to just
said location that you pick that you
think is a good place for you to fight
so you mix it up right so by the time
they come back next time we're not
exactly where you were where you're
still in that same area so you can kill
them again that makes them even more
angry sounds like a third time guess
what happens you're not in that same
spot bringing in that same area chances
are you killed them again hopefully you
get one or two of those guys and there
you go you have it
it's so depressing talking about like
being old and not being able to do
things but it's like the realization of
trying to just find your strengths and
like what you're really good at and just
capitalizing on that and the only way to
stay competitive is to adapt and to note
realize you know your weaknesses and
just want to pull forward hear your
strings and kind of not worried about
the pride anymore like I'm gonna run a
gun like those you know like the young
guys of course you can always try to be
more precise and accurate like I spray
too much right I feel like at the same
time you can't just feather all your
shots all the time don't always get
overzealous and go oh there's a guy his
backs to me I'm just gonna chase him and
get the easy kill because that's not
always the case because one either his
friend probably just wanted with them
and more so in this game than anything
else because of all the new movement
abilities of just being able to you know
double jump sidestep dash left right you
know they get hit a couple times and is
frantically you know they just jump up
in the air or like you know they do
things that they couldn't necessarily do
an old Cod's and we get away from you in
terms of light load outs I mean it's
going to depend on your level of course
I mean things like scavenger are like
really good because it gives you more
ammo so like if you do miss or whatever
you're not screwed trying to have to
find another gun because until I got
scavenger which unfortunately is later
down like I think it's like level 35
until I got scavenger it's like okay I'm
kind of not the most accurate person so
trying to shoot people and I don't kill
them or if I kill all these people that
I'm not gonna get ammo bag scavengers
obviously like really good just to build
upon that note like don't always spam
reload because I think in this iteration
it takes away bullets I mean in terms of
perks if you're trying to slow it down
and currently trying to just stay
undetected definitely want like low
profile blind eye cold-blooded blast
blast suppressor those things kind of
help keep you off the radar of course
silencer and your gun granted even
though like in this iteration they
finally added something that detects a
silencer but not every player is going
to use that so all these things kind of
help you stay hidden so to speak so it
gives you more chances to not
necessarily just be like I'm gonna have
a firefight with this other guy and
you're going to outright win so like
these things will help you give you like
those like slight advantages to keep you
alive so that you can kind of pick your
fights and make sure when you do pick
your fight you hopefully win it because
of all the movement now in the game it
seems like at least right now in the
early beginnings like because not
everyone knows how to use the movement
like to dodge and do everything well yet
they're kind of like one of the best
things to do is just try to be as high
up as you can because that gives you the
most visibility of the map people are
going to be trying to jump around and
like learn how to do their double jumps
and stuff like that and because of
because they're doing that if you're
already high up you'll be able to just
pick them off in the air and I think
you know the maps are kind of catered
that way now because they want you to
use the movement
you
you